[Música]
[Aplausos]
oi gente
eu acredito que ao longo das
experiências de vida da gente a gente
concluiu conclui coisas que são
realmente importantes
o melhor que a gente pode fazer com
essas coisas é compartilhar
então quero dar a vocês hoje a
oportunidade de perceberem como a gente
tende a sabotar a felicidade da gente
quando eu era bem pequeno bem pequeno
a minha mãe me deu o presente mais legal
que eu poderia ganhar que aos olhos de
qualquer outra criança ou de adultos
o presente não tinha graça nenhuma mas
pra mim o presente foi incrível
ela me deu um shortinho com um bolso e
eu fiquei tão feliz tão feliz que eu
sair do apartamento onde morava foi por
lote vago que era do lado do prédio
e aí olhei para o céu era de manhã o céu
estava lindo
os bolsinhos e aí eu dei dois passinhos
endereço tipo nada e pcs
quando eu crescer você é um homem muito
bonito e deu certo
[Aplausos]
mas o mais legal de ter ganhado um
shortinho é porque eu pensei nossa a
minha mãe tendeu tudo agora está tudo
resolvido na minha vida
só que aí um dia de os dias depois
voltou tudo ao normal e tiraram essa
foto de mim pode rir
de vestidinho e da eu que não bastava
tem que ter uma chapinha também olha a
minha cara olha tristeza eu postei no
facebook é no dia das crianças sim
quando cresceu de roubar essa toda
e aí eu pensei ela não entendeu né
há seis anos no aniversário de seis anos
os meus pais eram separados e aí meu pai
deu pra minha mãe o dinheiro para que
ela comprasse um presente pra mim me
levasse uma loja lá no bairro e comprar
presente para mim e quando a gente
chegou nessa loja é a loja naquela época
dividido brinquedos de menina do lado
brinquedos de menino do outro e aí eu
cheguei e ele uma coleção dos bombeiros
cheio de carris cadinho bonequinho falei
nossa é agora que eu vou pedir a coleção
aí a minha mãe vai juntar os e ela
vai entender tudo finalmente vamos
libertar
só que nessa hora a dona da loja me
olhou com aquela cara fuzilando aquela
caicos mais velhos foram pra gente assim
não faz isso senão você vai se
arrepender
e aí eu fiquei desesperado
olhei para o lado de cá vi que ele tanto
de boneca cada uma de tamanho diferente
com o tamanho de cabeça diferente com
cabelo diferente fiquei desesperado
chorei chorei chorei chorei e aí eu
chorei tanto que no princípio minha mãe
e ficou nervosa ela pensou em ser um
absurdo eu trouxe aqui vai ganhar um
presente vai poder escolher o presente
agora tá chorando desse jeito mas eu
chorei tanto que ela ficou com dó e aí
ela me levou pra casa e aí mais tarde
quando estava mais calmo ela perguntou
se eu queria voltar na loja
aí eu falei que eu queria e quando
cheguei lá eu escolhi uma calculadora
acho que um jogo de varetas e um ioiô
foi o jeito que eu arrumei de conseguir
ganhar o presente e não constrangê minha
mãe o que é isso que as pessoas trans
fazem então eu acredito que a maioria
delas fazem na infância elas escondem a
felicidade elas ocultam elas bloqueiam
comendo de constranger os pais às
pessoas que elas amam porque elas se
associam a felicidade delas é
constrangimento né
e aí quando inicia o processo de
transição há seis anos atrás de
transição é o que quando comecei a de
qual meu corpo quando também como
comecei a tomar os medicamentos e fazer
os procedimentos para que o meu corpo se
adequasse ao gênero no qual eu me
identifico
eu vi uma frase na internet que estava
na foto de uma tatuagem e eu carreguei
essa frase comigo durante todo o tempo
que eu passava por momentos delicados e
um desses momentos delicados
eu passei a dar o nome situação
zoológico o que a situação zoológico é
quando alguém sabe que eu sou trans e aí
essa pessoa acompanhado por alguém
e aí ela olha pra mim cochichou com essa
pessoa ou às vezes ela olha cochicha e
aponta pra mim às vezes pra piorar ela
chega e cumprimenta e fala que a pessoa
assim olha se o raul é um cara que eu te
falei é tão bizarro que só falta jogar
pipoca e aí eu passei a me interessar
por essas violências que eu considero
violência silenciosas e eu tinha uma
necessidade muito grande de querer
priorizar essas violências de poder
conceito a essas violências mas eu
percebi que faltava informação para
construir isso e eu não consegui essa
informação em qualquer lugar
e aí eu me interessei pelo curso de
filosofia porque acreditava que lá eu ia
ter acesso a várias construções que
foram naturalizados hoje e que me ajudar
a texto analisar as situações que eu
percebia
eu juro que eu quis fazer química
o motivo eu sempre gostei do desafio
queria fazer química só que como eu eu
não entendia nada até hoje não entendo
eu quero fazer química que eu preciso
entender aquela coisa toda mas isso foi
mais forte e aí eu fui pro filosofia e
aí me deu uma idéia eu queria comunicar
com as pessoas e fazer com que elas
perceber sem o quanto uma pessoa
transforma o constrangimento
eu queria que ela percebesse do mesmo
nível então eu pensei e localizar alguma
situação que as pessoas não transpassam
e que o poder no mesmo nível que eu
pudesse dar exemplos quando eu posso
falar sobre isso e eu encontrei nenhuma
nada só que eu passei a perceber uma
outra coisa
a minha namorada quando ela vai falar
com alguém conversar com alguém e quando
nessa conversa ela não conhece a pessoa
mas nessa conversa ela tem que remeteu
passado e ela tem que falar que ela já
se casou duas vezes e está no terceiro
relacionamento e eu espero que agora dê
certo a morretes e ela fala que mesmo
que a pessoa entenda a situação dela o
que a pessoa passa pela mesma situação
que ela o que a pessoa até se casou mais
vezes não importa
mesmo assim ela se sente constrangido
quando ela vai falar de dois casamentos
e as histórias constrangimento também
afeta a pessoa que por exemplo vai dizer
olha eu comecei o curso de direito mas
aí eu abandonei no meio e aí eu passei
por curso de administração depois de um
tempo mas eu também abandonei e hoje
estou fazendo curso de história sabe
quando a pessoa vai dizer não é porque
eu estou no meu terceiro emprego este
ano ou quando uma mulher vai dizer não é
porque são quatro filhos mas é porque
cada um de um casamento eu percebia que
o constrangimento era forte e que o pior
dos constrangimentos que não tem nada
pessoas podem fazer para poder apagar o
passado só que o problema não estava só
no constrangimento
o problema também estava no que elas
passavam a fazer no presente
devido esse constrangimento e eu percebi
que elas viviam de uma forma linear fixa
e fazer de tudo para não variar e aí
comecei a associar esse comportamento
com o comportamento que eu chamo de
comportamento empresa
uma professora uma vez me disse que se a
mac donald mudar se á logo o nome ela
perderia 75% da clientela dela mesmo que
ela manter se os mesmos produtos do
mesmo jeito porque ia perder a imagem de
confiança que as pessoas têm nela porque
a imagem fixa sem variar traz essa
confiança
então o processo acontece assim a
moralidade faz com que a gente tenha
vergonha do nosso passado variável e
para remediar essa vergonha e pra não
talvez não ter não passar por alguma
coisa que possa vir a ter
a gente passa a viver de uma forma
linear fixa este projecto uma vida e
fica só nela e faz de tudo para não
variar e então corar esse objetivo a
gente inventa a desculpa que é melhor
porque é o melhor o futuro
só aí com o tempo você começa a ficar
sem graça
os anos vão passando e você vai perdendo
a criatividade e aí vai surgir naquele
buraco que a gente tem não consegue
preencher
eu ano passado viagem de férias com a
minha namorada e eu disse pra ela olha a
gente vai ficar uma semana na chapada
diamantina e eu não quero falar que eu
sou uma pessoa trânsito e não quero
falar sobre questões trans
pela primeira vez eu quero passar umas
férias como qualquer outra pessoa
conviver normalmente sem falar sobre
isso
mesmo porque se eu falar sobre isso tem
pessoas que fazem tantas perguntas que
eu tenho que fazer a palestra igual essa
aí leva quatro horas aí eu perco passei
aí no poço azul né
e aí no terceiro dia eu passei a sentir
náusea dor de cabeça passar mal por que
não falar que eu sou trans é não falar
nada do meu passado
qualquer coisa do meu passado é
associado a isso que eu tive que ficar
calado
tudo quanto é assunto que eu tinha que
voltar ao passado eudes traía o eu
inventava um jeito de não falar e aí eu
passei mal
então é isso que acontece quando eu
tentei abafar o meu passado
por que você se bloqueia você se põe de
castigo como se faça um criança e vocês
a bota a sua felicidade
e aí você nega suas possibilidades
quando eu comecei o processo de
transição antes do processo quando
descobri que tinha como quando descobri
que está fadado a viver naquele corpo
que eu não me identificava isso em meus
29 anos quando eu percebi que eu não não
precisa eu não precisava de envelhecer
como uma velhinha de vestido colorido
que eu podia ser um velhinho
vocês podem pensar que eu joguei de uma
vez que eu agarrei com unhas e dentes
eu tenho o salto imediatamente mas não
foi assim eu sofrer sofrer sofrer muito
sofri durante dias
como é que uma pessoa pode sofrer se tem
diante dela possibilidade ela recebe a
realizar aquele sonho de infância
mas é porque ali onde o time estava em
um lugar seguro e eu tinha certeza do
depois
e assim se nessa incerteza não queria
passar por constrangimentos
então eu quase sabotei a minha
felicidade nessa hora a militância ela
luta bravamente até hoje é que as
pessoas têm o direito de exercer suas
identidades
mas não é só isso é mais do que isso
porque a identidade
ela é fixa e quando a gente consegue o
direito de dizer se ela a gente fica com
medo e passar a vida toda querendo
manter ela firme ea gente não há
identidade
é porque fixa engessado nós somos
possibilidades e possibilidade é você
ter o direito de estar no local de
conforto que você quiser e é ter o
direito de mudar esse local de conforto
quantas vezes você quiser é você lembrar
do passado variados e ao invés de sentir
constrangimento você lembrar que você
estava tentando tentando tentando porque
você quer ser feliz
e pensar que você está vivo e quando a
gente está vivo
a gente pega as fichas que a gente tem
ea gente joga elas de novo e de novo e
de novo de novo a permanecer feliz ea
nossa diferença em relação aos outros
animais é que nós podemos mudar nossa
trajetória quantas vezes a gente quiser
porque a gente é 6 possibilidade ea
gente tem o direito de ser o que quiser
de estar no local de conforto e esse
local de conforto pode ser um pode ser
vários eu agora estou no local de
conforto
eu estou feliz na vida que eu estou hoje
eu quero tá nessa vida durante um bom
tempo mas quando eu não quiser eu já
abri meu leque que eu possa apresentar
mais coisas nele mas eu tentei fazer uma
lista com todas as coisas que eu ainda
quero ser e fazer eu só esqueci de
colocar aí que eu quero andar de saia na
calçada da fama em nova york
eu tinha esquecido
tá amor você não não se importa com quem
ganhar um beijo na boca da madonna mas é
a maratona é dito tá
enquanto estiver vivo
eu vou tentar fazer todas essas coisas e
mais acontecer pelo caminho porque eu
tenho direito a todas elas
e quando eu morrer do dia que eu morrer
a única coisa que eu quero respirar e
quero falar com voz alta
falando num sorriso é que eu fui
especialista em realizações de possíveis
obrigado
[Aplausos]
ele